[Music]
welcome to Koch Che news Marvel is
discussing a comeback of the original
aventures including Iron Man there's
information about Five Nights at
Freddy's 2 and Disney is rethinking its
Snow White remake after receiving a lot
of criticism that and much more is now
being covered in this week's news so
stay
tuned some time ago it was announced
that a third part of the popular sakario
film series was in the works starring
Bono Del Toro now now rumors are
becoming increasingly prevalent that
some of the other characters in the
series might return alongside him in an
interview with kollider producers Molly
Smith and Trent luckenbill revealed that
in addition to Bono Del Toro Emily Brun
and Josh broland would also be
interested in reprising the roles for
sakario 3 there was also talk about who
could take over the direction among
others Mission Impossible director
Christopher mcquary is said to be a hot
Contender with whom they are already in
close contact the screenplay could once
again can be the work of Taylor Sheridan
who also wrote Parts 1 and two since
sakario 3 is currently still in a rather
early phase of development there is no
information about a release date or a
storyline yet but we will keep you up to
date as
always the God of Thunder could return
after all another Standalone movie of
Thor is on the schedule which according
to initial rumors however will come
along with a big change after Thor 4
love and thunder received mixed
reactions from fans and also failed to
live up to the box office takings of its
predecessor Thor Ragnarok it now seems
that Marvel wants to take a new approach
with a fifth installment as comic book
movie reports Hollywood Insider Daniel
Rickman addressed Marvel's plans for a
new Thor film in his solo podcast and
that apparently it will no longer be
directed by Tao ITI this decision
shouldn't come as much of a surprise
since the majority of fans can no longer
relate to itti's colorful and Goofy
style anyways actor Chris Hemsworth also
stated as a condition for his return
that the the character would have to be
subjected to a significant change in the
current MCU plans up to 2027 Thor 5 does
not seem to play a part at the moment
should there nevertheless be another
adventure of the God of Thunder then it
is not expected to happen anytime before
2028 we will keep you up to date on
further
developments the Five Nights at Freddy's
movie is currently running in theaters
and already director Emma Tammy is
talking about plans to make Five Nights
at Freddy's 2 one thing is for sure it's
a colossal task to turn such a popular
video game franchise as Five Nights at
Freddy into a feature film and meet the
expectations of millions of fans in an
interview with variety Emma Tammy
mentioned how difficult it was above all
to direct thrilling horror scenes that
would also be suitable for a young
audience she focused primarily on the
game itself which was more suspense and
heart-stopping moments rather than the
particularly gory scenes thus in the US
the movie received a PG-13 rating she
was especially happy about the guest
appear appearances of some influencers
who helped the games to become world
famous Mark fishbach AKA Markiplier who
was unable to be present due to a tight
schedule was one of the people she would
have loved to have seen on the big
screen however she would like to change
that in possible Five Nights at Freddy's
sequels in these sequels actor Matthew
liard is also planned to appear his
character development is intended to
take place over the course of three
films but according to the director the
success of the first movie must be
awaited if Five Nights at Freddy's 2 and
and Five Nights at Freddy's 3 are to
follow then she wants to base them on
Parts two and three of the video games
respectively beyond that there's of
course plenty of potential for further
adaptations after all the franchise
comprises 13 games and numerous
books there can be only one the first
rumors of a Highlander reboot starring
Henry caval already had fans excited now
more information has been announced that
should further increase the anticipation
according to deadline the production
company Lionsgate has secured the rights
to remake the movie of the legendary
swordsman and will provide it with a
budget of $100 million since the
Highlander reboot will be released in
2025 rumors are increasing that filming
could begin as early as next year in
terms of content initial information
suggests that the movie will be based on
the original from the 1980s director
Chad stahelski however wants to direct
it as kind of a John Wick with swords
the script will be written by Ryan J
Condell who previously worked on House
of the dragon at as well as Rampage with
Dwayne Johnson stahelski wants to
establish a new franchise with the movie
which will include various
interpretations and formats of the
Highlander brand for example a live
action and animated series and a
spin-off called Highlander The
Raven the original aventures could come
back for another film a plan that is
currently the subject of heated
discussion at Marvel whether Jonathan
Majors will stick around as the super
villain Kang however seems highly
doubtful at the moment as there is a lot
of unrest happening behind the scenes
the MCU is in trouble in serious trouble
the quality of the movies and Series has
been on the decline for years and the
interest of viewers is also dwindling
the people in charge are noticing this
too last September Studio Chief Kevin
feige and his colleagues discussed the
situation at an annual meeting in Palm
Springs there were three major topics
according to variety the many flops of
late the overwhelming workload of
streaming projects and the legal
scandals surrounding Jonathan Majors due
to the situation around the Kang actor
Marvel is locked in a stalemate since
Ant-Man and the WASP quantam Mania at
the latest he has been established as a
new major antagonist around which the
following movies and series are to
revolve according to insiders this is
also to be made clear once and for all
in the final episode of Loki on November
9th not to mention his titular role in
the new aventur movie The Kang Dynasty
when the first allegations of abuse made
against Majors emerged in Spring Marvel
was still playing for time as work on
the adventurers movie wasn't scheduled
to start until early 2024 anyway
unfortunately the situation continued to
worsen and the writer strike prevented
the company from adjusting its plan for
future projects according to internal
sources the idea of giving up Majors
already came up when Ant-Man 3 flopped
at the box office at the meaning in Palm
Springs various Alternatives have now
been discussed according to variety
including an alternate villain none
other than Dr Doom best known as the
antagonist of the Fantastic 4 even a
recasting of the Kang roll is not
entirely ruled out after all a recasting
has already happened a couple times in
the history of the MCU albeit only for
supporting roles the other two points of
criticism are closely related and can be
summed up as follows Marvel has taken on
too much at the end of phase three the
strategy was to never have a gap in
superhero content and to always have at
least one feature film or series running
the result was chaotic conditions behind
the scenes horor organization of
projects and over taxing of CGI teams
due to Impossible deadlines movies and
ser series were released with unfinished
effects people in charge like Victoria
Alonzo were fired and the CGI teams
joined together in a union to fight back
against the working conditions viewers
were also overwhelmed and tired of the
amount of content some of which could
only be comprehended if they had seen
everything else the mcu's only
theatrical hit was Guardians of the
Galaxy volume 3 by James gun in 2023 and
he is now the new head of Marvel's
biggest competitor DC of all places now
the question is what is Marvel planning
on doing to turn around the negative
Trend some measures are already
noticeable the reboot of Blade with
Mahala Ali was initially supposed to be
released in 2023 but was repeatedly
postponed and Rewritten due to Kevin
feige's dissatisfaction with the project
in addition its budget was lowered
significantly also the series Daredevil
born again was recently set back from
the start even though most of it had
already been shot less money less
pressure more time that seems to be the
new MCU approach for more quality and
reduced losses at least for some
projects but what about the really huge
projects the big Kang story is pending
and the new superheroes are having a
rather rough start with fans according
to various sources there are thoughts of
bringing back the old Adventures
including Robert Downey Jr as Iron Man
and Scarlett Johansson as Black Widow if
Marvel were to take this step it would
definitely not be a cheap movie there is
another glimmer of hope following the
Takeover of 21st Century Fox the X-Men
and the Fantastic 4 can finally be
integrated into the MCU thus Marvel has
some popular characters up its sleeve
that fans are interested in without
having to trouble any other Heroes for a
major hit we're eager to find out
whether Marvel can turn things around
what are your thoughts on the matter are
you still hopeful that the Marvel Brand
will soon represent quality again or is
it too late for that we can't wait to
read your opinions in the
comments news from Daredevil most
recently nearly all of the the material
for Marvel's new superhero series was
ditched now it seems that a new creative
team has been found to Breathe new life
into the project Daredevil born again is
undoubtedly one of the biggest series
projects that continue to be eagerly
awaited however the production of the
series has repeatedly attracted
attention due to problems most recently
with the discarding of the footage shot
so far and sacking of all the writers
and directors as stated by The Hollywood
Reporter Dario scardapane has been
chosen as the new showrunner he
previously worked on The Punisher series
and Tom Clancy's Jack Ryan among other
projects in addition the directing Duo
of Justin Benson and Aaron Morehead who
previously directed Loki and moonight
have been hired the number of episodes
Daredevil born again will comprise is
currently unclear Marvel will retain
some scenes and episodes from previous
production which will then be merged
with the newly shot the signings of Scar
depay Benson and Morhead could be an
indication that Marvel Now wants to work
more closely again with showrunners and
executive producers for their own TV
division to ensure a better quality of
their products it remains to be seen
whether and how this will be reflected
in the upcoming
series news about the fairy tale
princess Disney is postponing its
liveaction adaptation of Snow White to
2025 and published a first image as part
of the announcement the liveaction
adaptation of Snow White is probably one
of the most controversial projects that
Disney will be responsible for in the
next few years the production period of
the film was characterized by
storms and debates thus the announcement
that the film will now be postponed to
March 21st 2025 is likely to be met with
reserved reactions at least we now get a
first impression in the form of a
picture on which the character embodied
by Rachel zler can now be surrounded by
the Seven Dwarves during production
there was criticism of the plan to
replace the classic dwarves with magical
creatures of all shapes sizes and
genders so Disney now decided to replace
the former cast with animated characters
in addition to Snow White Pixar's
science fiction Adventure ilio is also
getting a new release date and will now
hit theaters on June 13th
2025 you still want to watch more
content well it's your lucky day on our
Channel we've got new movie previews for
Venom 3 and the Batman 2 as well as a
series preview about Netflix's upcoming
avatar The Last Airbender liveaction
series remake we hope you enjoy the rest
of your day thanks for
watching
[Music]